if there's anybody out there any young
guy for example
who's watching this
who's been having vengeful fantasies and
and who has been developing and toying
with fantasies of revenge and who is
feeling
isolated and lonesome and oppressed and
isolated and is starting to spin up
fantasies of violence in revenge
you know and you'll know that if you're
one of these people
like
find someone to talk to
there's better ways you can deal with
this and you're young you're 16 years 17
you don't have to be doomed you know you
got your whole life ahead of you and
maybe just getting out of the place that
you're in where you're unpopular might
do it for you you know you can move to
somewhere else and be a new person
there's all sorts of pathways in life
and so you don't have to
explosively demonstrate your competence
you know in a single vengeful violent
act there are better ways to deal with
the world and you might have reason to
be bitter and vengeful but
but there are better paths there are
better paths forward so don't do it do
what this
young man we talked about earlier did is
have enough sense to reach out to
somebody find someone a teacher a
principal someone
a policeman if it has to be
someone
[Music]
dr farrell has been chosen by the
financial times of london as one of the
world's top 100 thought leaders and by
the center for world spirituality as one
of the world's spiritual leaders his
books have been published in more than
50 countries and in 19 languages his
most recent book the boy crisis
co-authored with john gray was a
finalist for the indie book publishing
award
his other books include the new york
times bestseller why men are the way
they are
plus the international bestseller the
myth of male power
a book on couples communication women
can't hear what men don't say was the
selection of the book of the month club
and why men earn more
was selected by u.s news and world
report in 2006 as one of the top four
books on career a very practical book by
the way for men and women alike
contemplating how they might maximize
their earning power over the course of
their career
although that comes at other cost
obviously dr farrell has taught at the
university level in five disciplines and
appeared on more than a thousand tv
shows being interviewed repeatedly by
oprah and barbara walters as well as by
peter jennings charlie rose and larry
king
he's been featured multiple times in
forbes the new york times in the wall
street journal
he's also the only man
ever elected and three times to the
board of the national organization for
women in new york city
and currently as chair of the coalition
to create a white house council on boys
and men
he is working with the white house to
create such a council he teaches couples
communication courses around the country
and speaks internationally
on the global boy crisis its causes
and solutions and today unfortunately
we're going to be discussing
a series
a duo let's say of recent tragedies
catastrophes acts of malevolence in the
united states both in
new york and in texas the
unfortunately all too present and
all too
preoccupying mass school shooting and
we're going to delve into that pleasant
topic and try to see if we can make some
headway in a practical in a co what
would you say in a
in a conceptual and practical sense very
good to see you again warren it's a a
real pleasure to see you although i'm
sorry about the um stimulus for this of
course yeah well so let's dive right
into it i'll offer some ideas about what
i think is motivating this and but i
want to hear what you you've written so
much about well as we can see in the
background crisis of masculinity the
crisis among boys maybe you want to
define what that crisis constitutes and
then maybe zero in to the issue of
what's happening with these
mass homicides by committed almost
always by young men almost invariably
yeah we've we've seen a lot of theories
recently we've seen you know in buffalo
we saw the replacement theory style you
know hatred and everybody zoomed in on
that then we looked at the access to
guns as an issue we looked at toxic
politics we look at
family values are really bad in this
generation in particular we look at
violence in the media we look at
violence in video games
we look at mental illness obviously
anyone who does a mass shooting has a
mental illness problem
and then you ask a different question
which is wait a minute our daughters are
exposed to the same
replacement theory style hatred this the
same access to the same guns in the same
homes and they're the same family values
the same toxic politics the same
violence in video games the same
violence in the media and our daughters
are not doing the mass shootings
and they're not doing very little
shootings period
our sons are
and so it should be obvious to us that
there's something happening with our
sons and in fact there is and it's not
just happening in the united states it's
happening globally and it's happening
not just in and not in all countries
it's happening in all developed nations
in developing the 53 largest developed
nations boys are falling behind
in every academic subject but especially
reading and writing and reading and
writing as you know are the two biggest
predictors of success or failure
and so
failing in school is one thing
but then that failing if they if boys
who are dropping out of high school at a
much higher rate than girls and even
though they're being admitted to college
at a 60 40 rate only they graduate from
college now at about one half the rate
of daughters
daughters our daughters who graduate
from college are not usually looking for
a boy who has been a dropout in either
high school or college
girls tend to be attracted more to
winners
and boys who are drop out drop out are
also are perceived as losers
and um and yeah well that's a that's a
critical point there that we don't want
to gloss over which is that girls tend
to be attracted
to winners and so we know
cross-culturally that girls
when they're looking for a permanent
long-term mate so young women tend to
prefer boys who are four to five years
older and that's pretty stable
cross-culturally and that they tend to
be attracted to
males who are their equivalent in terms
of socioeconomic success or above
whereas with males the relationship
between socioeconomic success and female
attractiveness is virtually nil for boys
it's almost the only determinant of
their attractiveness so for a boy to be
a loser on the let's say competition
front especially given extreme female
sexual choosiness i was looking at data
today that showed that
women on data dating sites rate 80 of
men is below average
and whereas men men find 60 of the women
they look at on online dating sites
acceptably attractive women find 4.5 of
them acceptably attractive and so
there's this nexus between
success in the competitive workplace and
between men say and attractiveness to
women that drives male motivation in a
way that's virtually inconceivable on
the female front and we don't take this
sort of thing with any degree of
seriousness
we don't and it really is it's very
crucial because the
it makes the boy crisis globally
more than just a boy crisis it means
that the boy is feeling like he's being
rejected sexually and rejected and
relationship wise and very few of us
know that that when boys and girls break
up in a relationship we usually think of
the girls as being more depressed in
fact the data shows that the boys are
more depressed when you know how to
measure boy depression but most of the
measures of depression have been based
on females expression of depression not
males repression of depression and so um
so that's that's a whole other area that
has to be worked on but but when a boy
is feeling like he's being rejected um
sexually and relationship wise and is
feeling like his his teachers are not
speaking well of him because he's not
doing well in class and his parents are
maybe speaking about his brother or
sister with a pride in their voice but
sort of leaving him out he begins to
feel this
enormous vulnerability but in this but
also that vulnerability is expressed by
anger as well
bitterness resentment desire for revenge
yep yep all of that and fantasies that
emerge as a consequence of that too
fantasies of revenge and and the
acquisition of status
that's exact that's exactly right and
these boys
and so they sort of turn to
they may turn to guns as a way of saying
you know i'm strong um i'm not that not
not the loser that you think i am as you
know did with in in texas and not only
did he show the guns on tick tock and on
instagram but also try to to tease anita
um a girl that he
thought he knew who didn't know him at
all um basically um and he was hoping to
sort of get her attention by saying you
know i'm going to be doing something
important
right watch out for me oh i didn't know
it had become that detailed in
relationship to a relationship yeah so
well she would say it was not a
relationship right right right it was a
fantasy on his part it was a fantasy on
his part for sure um and and so what you
know when as i started studying this i
saw that it is not just the boy crisis
but that the boy crisis resides where
dads do not reside
and so when we look at the mass the six
mass shooters in the
21st century who have been school
shooters uh who have um the those all
six of those mass shooters who have been
school shooters in the 21st century um
all six of them for whom we know the
family background um every single one of
them were dead deprived boys including
um you know in texas and the you know
the stories are so amazingly similar
the dads are not involved
the mothers become involved they care
for the children a great deal but the
boy feels he has no
sort of no structure no purpose no
discipline
dads are far more likely especially with
their sons
to require their sons to be very good
with boundary enforcement mothers tend
to be more
more effective with just empathy and
saying
sweetie you know you have a wonderful
voice you should sing you should you
know you're you're really good at acting
you should act um but the but acting and
singing in any accomplishment takes a
great deal of discipline and the dad is
more likely to say don't expect us to
get a tutor for you or for me to drive
you to school to for this you know for
the special practice that you're doing
for basketball um if you're not if
you're not practicing at home and doing
these other things um and the mom is
saying you don't be mean he's upset that
you're not doing that whereas the dad
will say no i need to make it clear to
him that he can't just manipulate
everything he'd do everything he wants
to do and expect us to take him
everywhere and not have the discipline
to succeed himself not without a quid
pro quo
so what do you mean by exactly by
boundary enforcement in that situation
and the difference between mothers and
fathers in that yes
a mom will be much more likely to say
moms and dads will both set boundaries
almost the same way one of the biggest
misunderstandings in parenting is not
understanding the difference between
setting boundaries versus enforcing
boundaries so moms and dads when um both
when a mom is with a child more than a
dad
she tends to set um bedtimes
that are uh that are earlier dad said
set later bedtime so you think oh the
dad is more lenient but the studies show
that the children with dads get to bed
in fact earlier than the children with
moms because moms tend to do something
like um set they set the bedtime let's
say at 8 30 and the child it comes to 8
30 and and the child says oh i haven't
finished my homework and mom goes oh my
goodness i definitely don't want you to
go to school without finishing your
homework okay sweetie you know you can
you can um spend a little bit more time
finishing your homework and she monitors
and sees and then that becomes nine
o'clock oh you didn't read me a story
okay
since you did your homework that was
good that you did that and now it's 9 15
9 30.
dad is more likely to say some version
of um and you know the data bears this
out
dad is more likely to say some version
of um i'm sorry you didn't do your
homework um you had all this time to do
it um you're gonna
go to class and not do your homework
well all right tough luck for you rat go
to bed
do better next time yeah do you know
warren if there's been any studies
linking that capacity for boundary
enforcement
to personality traits like agreeableness
has that has the work being done that
that fine-grained level
i do i don't know for sure about the
agreeableness per se
but the the i think one of the
misunderstandings about moms and dads is
that behavior that agreeable behavior is
considered by moms as being like
unconditional love
whereas we whereas we don't use the word
unconditional love nearly as often with
our dads but in fact our dads have
unconditional love but for them part of
unconditional love is having conditional
approval
yeah well that i think maybe that's the
distinction between it's something like
the distinction between that
all-encompassing maternal acceptance
that's maybe at the core of infant care
and the encouragement that's more
patriarchal or patristic
to develop and those things are those
things are juxtaposed to some degree
because the universal love is well
you're okay exactly the way you are and
we accept you but the conditional love
is
no you have to grow up when and because
we love you we don't want you to stay
infertile we want you to develop
competence we want you to be
not only socially acceptable but
socially sophisticated productive
generous and that's all conditional on
well very high level of behavior
absolutely and we see this also
exactly right
um and we see this even the way parent
family dinner nights are constructed and
we you know we all know that family
dinner nights are highly correlated with
a healthy family and healthy healthy
children but many family nights
deteriorate into family that are
nightmares um by the mother and father
sort of uh interrupting the child when
she or he is talking or arguing a
different you know a different
perspective on something and then the
child feels like and then you notice the
child is talking quite um voluminously
to their girlfriend or boyfriend but not
to the parents and when you the parents
ask them something they go they just
shut up before they start up because
they don't want to be um interrupted um
but the parents that are really good at
listening to the children are oftentimes
filled with empathy without
understanding that
being only empathetic toward a child
does not produce an empathetic child it
produces often a self-centered child
right right
that is filled with himself um and so
part of you know what part of what i
discovered was so important in family
gender nights
is to make sure that the children also
um are required not encouraged but
required to also listen to the parents
perspective without interrupting them
and
and to empathize with it and say mom dad
you know what i hear you say is this is
that correct did i distort anything and
did i miss anything is there anything
you want to add mom or dad well very few
children do that to their moms and dads
right
unfortunately that's that great
technique that was pioneered by carl
rogers right listen
and summarize to the other person's
satisfaction yes it's a great it's a
great communication style it it's very
annoying if you're trying to win an
argument with someone and just crush
them but if you actually want peace
then it's a wonderful communication
style
and so yeah well this this uh see let me
run a couple of things by you tell me
what you think about this so
i was talking to friends to wall the
other day primatologists who studied
chimp behavior and one of the things he
said was that
you give female juveniles chimps a block
of wood that's you know about this big
say
they'll frequently carry it around in
their arms or carry around their back
like an infant and
and care for it like a doll even though
it's just a block of wood
and the males juveniles do not do that
and if you give the female chimps a doll
a
teddy bear or a doll or a chimp doll
whatever they will definitely care for
that and then they will share it with
their compatriots because chimps
essentially have friendships and
they will become extraordinarily upset
if the people that
or the chimpanzees that they're
associating with don't take proper care
of the doll if you give a doll to a
juvenile male he'll tear it apart to see
what it's made of and so
and so that it's the infantile it's the
projection of the infant onto the block
of wood that's particularly interesting
to me because one of the things i see
happening i would say on a broad scale
level in our society this is perhaps
where this will might get somewhat
contentious is that
i think with that
with the feminine ethos that's centered
on infant care which is an
extraordinarily important thing to be
centered on given the dependency of our
infants
imagine the world is sort of divided
into three parts there's infants
there's infant caregivers
and there's predators
and so infants can do no wrong infant
caregivers are motivated by the highest
and noblest of motivations which is
essentially uh
all-encompassing empathy and anyone who
isn't either of those two things is to
be regarded with severe suspicion
and that's a very good ethos if you're
dealing with infants but it's a very bad
ethos if you're dealing with
well larger scale social organizations
and i see
i was
reading these guidelines for faculty
members at mount royal college in
calgary and uh for a faculty retreat you
know which is really not one of the
world's most dangerous
uh
what would you say happen happenings yes
and
all of the faculty members were assured
that trained counselors would be at hand
in case the discussion became intense
beyond the point of tolerability and i
thought what's going on here it's like
well the faculty members are infants and
those who oppose their ideas are
predators and the appropriate moral
ethos is
to care for the infants and it's like
well yeah except no because they're not
infants and this is not
mother and baby and this is also to me
it's also an exp extension of the
freudian nightmare the edible nightmare
that produces both dependency and
narcissism as a consequence of
the over-extension the unregulated
over-extension of that essential ethos
directed at infants yes is that too
harsh
i don't think so at all and i think i
think that that mothers and fathers just
have such different styles of parenting
and you know with the common goal we all
want our children to do well we all care
about them and
but
the uh and but what we know
what i saw when i did the research for
the boy crisis is that the children that
didn't have dads in their lives even the
girls did worse in 50 different areas
they were more likely the boys as well
but the boys more intensely in those
areas both
boys and girls who didn't have a lot of
dad involvement by the age of nine and a
half their telomeres were shorter um wow
14 shorter on average that's the average
between boys and girls when a ch when a
father was not involved in a significant
way by the time that child was nine and
a half however the telomeres of the
boys were yet again forty percent
shorter than the telomeres of the girls
and many people don't know that the
length of telomeres when you're nine and
a half years of age is one of the best
predictors of your life expectancy
um the you know the telomeres you know
carry of course the you know the the the
genes that tell you whether you're
subject to get to cancer or vulnerable
to any you know any set of diseases and
so the fact that right they're
determiners of senescence right of the
onset of senescence essentially yes wow
and so it's that basic is it that basic
and that early and and and that early
and that may and and the impact on both
girls and boys i mean there are certain
differences between the lack of father
on girls versus boys for example girls
who don't have very much father
involvement are far more likely to be
pregnant as teenagers because they
either that that's oftentimes by not
having father involvement they don't
know how to
interact in a very socially nuanced way
with a boy they
they do know though that then they're 13
14 years of age that that boy wants sex
and so if the there's another girl that
might give him sex and she wants to keep
the boy and not have him go to the other
girl
she'll go ahead and be sexual and if he
doesn't want to wear a condom okay he
doesn't want it she doesn't want to make
his sexual experience one that well she
has no she has no experience under those
conditions negotiating with any male i
know the data
the data i remember it's a few years old
now indicated quite clearly that girls
with fewer brothers were much more
likely to be raped and i i presume and
i've i've seen
you know brotherless uh
girls among my clients for example some
of whom were prone to sexual assault in
in uh for all sorts of reasons
they had no idea how to negotiate no at
an early stage yes so by the time they
were
frightened enough to object
it was often so far along the unwanted
amorous advance cycle that it was very
difficult for things to stop and of
course the guy on the other end presumes
often as unsophisticated as his victim
is
presumes that consent has already been
obtained at that point the the
girls with brothers have learned how to
negotiate at that really embodied level
you know the same embodied level that
probably emerges
or underlies sophistication that emerges
out of rough and tumble play with
fathers and absolutely and so on so
yeah i know i mean the the
the the paternal involvement seems
really to me to boil down to something
like a kind of uh
uh
a conditional encouragement it's like
i really want the best for who you could
be and i'm also confident in your
ability to attain that and so i can hold
you to high standards and enforce it
because i think so much of you so much
of what you could be
yes and i think that is a lovely
juxtaposition with that more maternal
sense of you always have a home here
will accept you in some real sense no
matter what you do not that women don't
put conditions on their children because
of course they do but
we're talking about
the way that's expressed in a very
practical sense yes and and okay so so
these boys that let's let let's look at
the more extreme case for a minute these
these school shooters so my
understanding of their psychology
is that
they're resentful they're
they're low down on the status hierarchy
they're not attractive to potential
mates they're not necessarily very
popular they don't
and they don't have a lot of hope for
attaining any of that in the future so
they're very very frustrated by that
lowly position
and that makes them angry it makes them
resentful then it starts to generate
compensatory fantasies which would be
well i'll do something i'll show them
i'll show them i'll show them i'm going
to be famous everybody's going to know
who i am
and then they drift and they drift into
they can drift into these violent
fantasies and some sometimes that's
motivated also by thoughts of direct
revenge because they've been bullied and
they've been pushed around and so they
have
reasons to be angry let's say no i'm not
saying any of this is justified by the
way i'm just saying how it works and
then they brewed for months
weeks months and years developing these
fantasies of violence but more
importantly focusing on
the
consequences for notoriety of the
violent act and so
one of the things that um i've been
suggesting to
to people who are interested in this
sort of thing is especially
people on the media side is that they
don't use the shooters names they don't
report the shooters names
and i think because the thing about this
the mass shooters in particular is
they've learned how to hijack
the
media world to provide themselves with
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
free publicity to draw attention to
their manifestos for example but also
and then they can have these fantasies
it's like a the same kind of fantasy
that a suicidal teenager will have
because the suicidal teenager will often
fantasize about as if he's a spirit that
will be there at his funeral
everybody huddled around the coffin
including the boys and girls who
who rejected him
expressing their sympathy for the way
that he behaved expressing their sorrow
for for
for the mistreatment that he suffered
the parents are doing the same thing and
he sees this in a very dramatic sense
and there's an elaboration of that on
the violent side
and and and they want to be notorious
and you ask why and why boys not girls
and the answer is well success to boys
is linked with
popularity with girls for example in a
way that it's simply not linked for
girls with boys and it's a huge
difference
so do you see anything wrong in that you
and i had an interesting experience that
i wanted to touch on so part of the
reason i reached out to warren in the
aftermath of these events is because
he got a letter
six months ago something like that
from uh
do you to you want to tell the story go
ahead and tell the story
um i opened my email and i saw a letter
from somebody um who was a hispanic
young man in texas actually and he um
and he said to me um
uh you know thank you for the boy crisis
book and he said um i was raised by my
dad and i was raised by um i'm sorry i
was raised by my mom without a dad um
and then i was passed on to my aunts who
um both neither had a father or a man a
husband in their life or a man or a
boyfriend in their life that has passed
on to my grandmother she didn't have a
man in the life none of them liked men
very much
i heard negative things about my father
um but i never really saw much or
anything of him
and um and so i didn't i didn't have any
structure i didn't have any purpose um
so i got involved with 4chan and then i
got involved with ahn and nah-chan is a
fascist group and the fascist group gave
me something i could count on an
ideology it gave me structure it gave me
purpose it gave me a sense like a gang
yes it's very much like a gang um
gangs give you respect when you don't
feel you have respect you you get the
gang's promise you respect i should say
and so you you become part of that
family and so and he felt very much part
of that family so he told me so i wrote
up a 52-page manifesto that was uh
overlapping in its effectiveness i
thought it was even better than the two
other people at um a chan who had become
celebrated mass shooters um and um and
he said i was ready to
i was making the plans to carry it out
and in the process i stumbled across um
the this the boy crisis book
and what
and what he said to me was very powerful
he said it wasn't the data
that got to me it was being seen that
you saw it was like you were a spy in my
life
telling me what i was feeling uh the the
hurt that i had the the lack of
structure the lack of purpose uh the
loss of self the feeling that i didn't
have that and boundary enforcement
therefore i didn't have that discipline
i um i didn't have anything that uh
anybody that would tell me that's too
much that's too little that's you know
you're doing it wrong
um and so and you could do better and
you could do better and you were
explaining all that
and
just being seen
from my vulnerabilities
made me not have the energy that i had
to begin to continue carrying out my
what i have outlined in my manifesto and
so we ended it by saying you know thank
you for saving not just my life but the
live lives of countless others because i
was really working this so there would
have been countless others um so i would
have been seen as um as be doing
something that he felt was positive um
that is helping the fascist um ideology
to uh
to be more broad spread and so you know
what i really
my my heart
is
saying to people that i hear is that
when we see a mass shooter we see
somebody with um
in this type of
modality we have we see that they're
angry and we tend to have anger
at their anger
as opposed to having empathy
at their vulnerability
and what i what what this fellow was
telling me was you had empathy at my
vote about my vulnerability
and when i saw that you saw my
vulnerability
i lost my anger or my anger diminished
enough
to not make me want to follow a
follow-through so systematically on my
52-page manifesto and i did end up going
to a couple of psychologists i did a few
sessions with him as well i talked
wrote to you about it you gave me some
guidance guidance as to what to do with
them
and so
and and almost the exact same pattern
happened uh with also in texas um he was
doing
poorly in school he dropped out of
school he had a speech impediment uh he
was being bullied um he was
feeling like he was a failure on on
almost every aspect of life
and and then he began um i i was
mentioning to you i think offline that
he that he had this this girl a fantasy
about a girl named anita and he was uh
texting her and saying i'm going to be
um
see my guns here on tick tock see my
guns on uh instagram um and uh watch out
for me anita i'm going to be doing
something and he's going
get out of here you know just like i
don't know you um but well that shows
you the degree of fantasizing right
because what that means in some sense is
that to put myself in his position which
is of course an uncomfortable thing to
do is he's constructed this girl in his
imagination
and she
uh would be
you know maybe she looked at him one day
and that would be enough
and now he's imagining that if he can
only elevate himself
to to notor
to notorious status
that he would become an
object of admiration and god only knows
how many
hundreds of hours he might have spent
fantasizing about that fantasizing about
the relationship he'd have with the girl
and how much she would admire him and
how everyone would know his name and you
don't get to the point where you do
something like shoot up the school
without i would say literally hundreds
of hours of fantastic dreaming about the
about the event about the day about
mostly about
what's going to happen afterwards and
how your name is going to be on
everyone's lips it's so striking a that
that that that young man who reached out
to you
was deterred
by
what was essentially an accurate
diagnosis of his situation and that was
sufficient you know when i'm out on my
tours talking to audiences many of whom
are young men
um who are suffering the consequences of
the sorts of things that we've been
discussing the thing that's been so
terrible to me to see is
to the degree to which
so many of them are suffering so
intensely for lack of a single
encouraging word
yes you know and it's it's so sad that
they have to get that from me on youtube
or in a lecture that they haven't had
anyone in their life and we're in this
situation now where you know
frequently any manifestation of
masculine ambition in in even in just
juvenile forms to show the desire to
engage in rambunctious play let's say is
instantly associated not only with
pathology that needs to be medicated
let's say in the case of adhd which i do
think is a disorder of uh repressed play
and yak pancett did a lot of work
showing that that might be the case
um but also that
you know we associate that male ambition
with well the force that's literally the
patriarchal oppressive force that's
literally destroying the world it's like
well how the hell do you expect young
men to react to that the answer might be
something like well there's two bloody
many people on the planet anyway and if
we stopped running around doing things
things would be a lot better it's like
well that really leaves them nowhere to
go doesn't it yeah so accept well except
to some very dark places in some
situations
i was um uh doing some uh somebody was
filming me talking about these issues
the other day and um we were in the
middle of uh we were we were in a little
island in the middle of a creek and um a
a young man who looked like he was about
16 15 was passing by and i said and he
showed some curiosity about the filming
and i said
i asked i signaled him over here i said
could you join us for a moment i said
you know in in high school are you in
high school and he says yes and he said
i was um sophomore and he said um you
know do you uh what do you learn about
men and women or boys and girls or
sexuality and stuff like that in high
school and he said oh you know i hear i
guess the word toxic masculinity a lot
and he said i said anything else and he
said oh yeah the teachers are always
talking about we're part of the
patriarchy and um you know men
especially white men are really the
oppressors
and then i said anything else and he
said yeah male privilege is always
coming up you know if i do well it's
because i have male privileges if i
don't do well uh it's because um i don't
do well i'm a loser
anything else he says you always hear
the future is female and um i said how
does that make you feel about your
future he laughed you know
in accordance good he could laugh yeah
he mean he laughed sadly so i said then
um if you're out on a date are you going
out on dates yet yes yes i am um and uh
he said i said do you talk to your girl
the girl you're dating about this and he
goes no what no way i never bring it up
um i said you know well why not and he
said because i i just assume that they
get it i get we get into an argument and
that would be the end of any um any
further romance right and he's i said
well what about if you really got to
know her well like a year or two and you
were really intimate with her
and then he said well i haven't had that
long a relationship yet but i really
hope i could
and it was almost like this deep sadness
i really hope i could
share what was in my heart about that
and there's so many yeah what we're
doing is what we're doing is awful it's
it's absolutely awful i when i was
talking to friends to wall i read part
of his book on difference and there was
this section that he cited from a female
author who
she said she threw up her hands in
dismay because she couldn't stop her
young boy from
playing with guns she took everything
that was even remotely resembling a gun
out of the house and then she caught him
one day
you know
shooting the toothbrush at the cat bang
bang bang and instead of noticing that
he had this male propensity to aim and
shoot that was deeply rooted in her son
she was appalled to the core by his
intractable masculinity and believed
that her
uh what would you say ideologically
adult sense of what constituted
masculine behavior was so
morally admirable that it was perfectly
fine to her to be disgusted by the fact
that no matter how hard she oppressed
her son he was still a boy and all of
that was couched in this moral terms and
i thought you witch
that's that's absolutely unforgivable to
see that as such an intrinsic part of
your boy's character and then to throw
your hands up in moral dismay about
exactly this patriarchal oppression and
and uh the toxic masculinity and all of
that it's and then the boy you talk to
to
so he's damned if he does and he d and
he's damned if he doesn't and why is
that i here's a hypothesis for you
so i don't know what i don't know what
you make of this but
let's imagine that you have a woman
who's never had a good relationship with
a man in her life and maybe this is a
consequence of disrupted familial
structure too right so
multi-generational consequence of
disrupted familial structure
and so
she's
and maybe the relationships she's had
have not only been absent but bad
and so then that woman has a very
difficult time discriminating between
male competence and male
power compulsion right because
it's not easy to distinguish
in authority power
and competence from compulsion
and so imagine you don't have much
experience with that and so you're so
terrified of anything that's male
because you've had a pathological
history with males not that i'm
attributing that to the women i'm saying
this is part of this pattern of
disruption is that
you're primed to regard any display of
masculine
will as
indistinguishable from oppression and
compulsion and so then what are you
going to do well when your son manifests
that you're going to crush it because
you think it's bad because you can't
discriminate and
that seems to me to be well another one
of the consequences let's say of the
multi-generational and cumulative
consequences of fatherlessness yes yeah
and we see this so much even with this
young man that i was just talking to you
about he was um
he said in school you know he learned
they learn and in california it is the
law by the way something called
affirmative consent and in half the
states in the united states that's in
the legislative process at the moment
and affirmative consent means if you're
in college let's say mostly in college
and if you if you ask a girl or woman on
a date uh and she says yes and you reach
out and touch her hand and hold her hand
before she
says without asking her may i hold your
hand you have violated affirmative
consent and you can be considered
sued by her as being a sexual harasser
so right right well that's exactly that
well and that's why you brought up
that's a cardinal example of the
inability to distinguish between male
will and oppression so let me let me ask
you about that so i've been thinking
about
the violation of the principle of
non-contradiction in our society which i
think is a hallmark of looming insanity
so
here's what we're here's what college
kids are asked to swallow now as far as
i can tell
every single manifestation of sexual
interest or sexual orientation of any
conceivable sub
type is to not only be tolerated but to
be
celebrated and celebrated in some sense
under compulsion and by force of law no
discrimination whatsoever on the basis
of sexual behavior or sexual preference
okay and simultaneous so no sexual
interest is so
abnormal let's say in the technical
sense that
you can put up any barriers against its
expression whatsoever conceptually or
otherwise and
simultaneously
every single act of sexual interest
between a young man and a woman is so
dangerous and so pathological that you
need something approximating
contractual consent to engage in the
simplest of
simplest acts of initial physical
intimacy so how the hell can both of
those things be true at the same time
yeah and the this
the the feedback i'm getting from kids
young people this age is on the one hand
i'm being told
this um you know don't
don't take an initiative unless you have
you know ask for permission and
um and and get and get a yes and then
other times girls are laughing at me for
doing that and in real life i don't see
the problem with that nearly as much as
the the guys that are um that are that
are behaving that way they're they're
thought of as wimps and
or they don't take the initiatives at
all because they're not they're not
secure in
the possibility that they will be
rejected so they're invisible to the
girls that they're interested in right
well the girls can't distinguish between
that deep inadequacy
that emerges as a consequence of not
being attended to enough and that would
include not engaging enough in rough and
tumble play and all the things that make
you like a sophisticated dancer let's
say the girls cannot distinguish between
that and the enforced awkwardness that
comes with imposing an arbitrary
imposition on the initial stages of
physical intimacy how could they
distinguish especially when they're like
13 or 14. and so we're definitely
putting we're putting boys and girls in
a completely impossible position
and
we're doing something really also awful
which is where
we're saying to boys
um that you if you move too quickly
you're a harasser if you don't move
quickly enough you're a wimp or you'll
never be seen but we're not saying to
girls um
that
what what to do how to assert themselves
we're not saying to girls it is
it is not just an option to share the
risks of rejection it is an expectation
on you to share the risks of rejection
not just the risks of rejection with the
20 of boys that are the superstars and
really outstanding but with any boy you
have an interest in um that if you're
expect yourself to reach out will you be
rejected more absolutely anyone who
takes risks in life will be rejected but
our job is to prepare you not ju
to prepare you as girls to take risks
because there's there's no
entrepreneur who's successful without
taking risks there's no um
and and so your job is to take risks now
what about if a boy uh reaches out to
you and said and you don't really wan
and
it's moving too quickly
so your job is to say
no
not now
but if i ch and maybe not ever but if i
change my mind
i'll let you know because i now see that
you're interested
um and so i don't have to worry about
rejection but don't keep trying to be
sexual with me i'll take the
responsibility for reaching out because
feminists say
what is there about know that you don't
understand
well here's what there is about no that
that is often not understood is it no
forever
not interested in me at all is it no
till maybe i say yes to another date
is it no until i have maybe some wine to
relax me is it no until i have some
coffee to wake me up is it no until we
we play some music and i feel very
intimate with you after the music is
being played should i turn the music up
should i turn the music down or were you
talking too much about yourself and not
about me are you talking too much about
me and not about yourself
um all of these things are part of what
happens in the industry right right well
part of that is well that's exactly it i
mean when you object to someone you see
this in fights between couples it's like
well
is this like a divorce fight or is this
like we talk for 10 minutes and make
peace fight and or is it one of the
intermediary
stages along that pathway how serious is
this and no has exactly that ambiguity
like is this an outright rejection by
every female in the world forever is it
a harbinger of that because it could be
and that is certainly the lot of many
men because there are i would say what
five percent of men maybe 10 of men are
in the category of so
undesirably undesirable socially that
they have virtually no chance whatsoever
in the mating market it's a great
documentary about that by the way
documentary called crum that was done
about probably 25 years ago that focuses
on
three brothers one who became very
famous a very famous artist all three
extremely talented men but all three of
them
toxically unpopular in high school to a
to a degree almost unimaginable by
anyone who was actually in a you know an
acceptant peer group and who had at
least some chance on the dating market
one of the brothers committed suicide
soon after the movie was finished
documentary and the other was put in
prison as a sexual offender so it's a
very dark movie but documentary it's
it's about the best documentary i've
ever seen on anything but
if you're interested in the uh
psychopathological fantasies of sexual
offenders that's definitely the
documentary for you because they're
extraordinarily well documented in a way
that
well that anyone with any sense would
shy away from it's very dark stuff
um the
the successful brother robert crum who
is a
a very successful underground comic
artist in the 1960s late 60s in san
francisco it really started the whole
underground comic movement
he
became quite famous as a consequence of
his artistic work and then became quite
popular with women and it was a it's he
tells the story it was an absolute shock
to him because he went from he wasn't no
one he was way less than no one
no one would be to move up the ladder by
a large margin you know he was in the
detestable category which is that's
disgust right that's damn low on the
hierarchy and then when he became
successful that all switched on him and
pretty much overnight and so part of the
documentary which is done so
unbelievably brilliantly is an
exploration of that dynamic i've never
seen anything like it so i would highly
recommend that it's called crum
great documentary i've shown it like i
show it like 20 years in a row in my
personality class to illustrate the
freudian dynamic of edible
and smothering mothering essentially and
all the toxic consequences of that so
anyways
um
yeah back to back to uh
to know
yeah well no and yes those are very
difficult things to negotiate i don't
think there's anything more difficult to
negotiate between a man and a woman
than no and yes or between any two
people that are in an intimate
relationship or beginning one it's like
what don't you understand well there's
an infinite number of things i don't
understand and what makes you so clear
so sure you're so damn clear about your
communication
and so
we have this perfect opportunity for
teaching our daughters that you can say
no
and say i'll take responsibility for
anything i am interested from this point
on as opposed to you keeping on trying
you know we're doing tongue kissing and
the average girl knows that you know if
if there's no no somewhere uh they'll be
you know having intercourse in about
five six ten minutes um and for many
girls or women that's too quick uh so
there and so she pulls out the tongue um
but then the pulling out of the tongue
does that mean um you know respect her
that the tongue is being pulled out and
then when do you put the tongue back in
when do you restart the process again
well it's also quite difficult if she's
confused about it which she's likely to
be because it's not like that's not a
male strum of conflicting motivations
and emotions should i continue how much
do i like this boy am i going to be a
[__] is this something i'm going to
enjoy what are my girl what are my
girlfriends going to think is this the
guy for me is this something casual is
casual sex okay um am i going to get
pregnant can i can i take revenge on my
absent father by falling in love with
this loser etc etc
a hundred fold and oh if if that wasn't
complex we wouldn't have any movies or
novels it's unbelievably complex
yes
i just came back from mexico and almost
every woman that was reading a book was
reading some type of romance novel
and
one of them was a very strong feminist
that i got into a conversation with and
i sort of
challenged her on that and she goes
i know
but i still love it
it was really yeah but but but that's
also not funny in my you know in some
deep sense so so i read this book called
uh
billion wicked thoughts that
google engineers had put together by
analyzing patterns of pornography use
among men and women and it's really
quite a brilliant book and
because they're engineers it's it's
really apolitical they just looked at
the data they are not political they
just said what it said and they found
that
men and women both used pornography uh
with men it was all pictures and with
women it was all written
it was all literary and they identified
the five categories of porn
star in these romance
in these literary romance
pornography representations
pirate
vampire surgeon billionaire i don't can
never remember the fifth but they're all
it's the same pattern they identified it
perfectly it's beauty and the beast
high status dangerous male
tamed by
attractive female
and enticed into a reciprocal
relationship yes but with difficulty
right and so and then the the the sexual
component of it is
mutual exploration yes and no
tension
conflict and the resolution of that but
the guy but what's so interesting about
it and it's the same pattern in 50
shades of grey it's exactly the same
thing is that
the guy isn't
a
pushover
he's actually someone very forward in
every way but capable of of being
restricted capable of responding to the
imposition of boundaries
and then also capable of establishing a
relationship but
the the fact of his willfulness in some
sense is core to the sexual
attractiveness well that's no different
than the manifestation of male ambition
on the status hierarchy it's exactly the
same thing and why we have to lie about
this is it's sickening to me and it's
unbelievably destructive both for men
and women i mean it's not like the girls
are benefiting from any of this they're
having catastrophic relationships in
college you know in these you get these
colleges now where it's like
60 or 65 girls
and you think well that's a hell of a
good thing for the guys
because they have this plethora of women
and it's not because first of all it's
still 10 of the guys and maybe they have
carte blanche on the sexual front but
all that does is treat teach them to be
narcissistic psychopaths because they
can have a different one night stand
every day of the week and that's a hell
of a training ground for establishing a
permanent relationship and then the
other guys well they're in the same
position that guys generally are which
is they're chasing after scarce
resources and the girls they're
completely frustrated because
the high status guys have zero interest
in pursuing a long-term relationship
and so that's a lovely situation i i
heard some some recent
not so much data but some stories from
people in
universities
where the girl-to-boy ratio is climbing
above 70 and they say the girls stopped
applying at about that point well it
isn't only the application to schools
and the getting in schools which is
creating a whole
possibility and in some cases actuality
of affirmative action in favor of the
boys now but the dropout rate among the
boys in college is much greater and so
in the next few years it's predicted
that the ratio of female to male
graduates will be two to one
two female to one male and that creates
this whole you know the the thing that i
was saying before about you know the
women are not women who graduate from
college generally speaking want a man
who's at least a college graduate um and
so if if she's only half as likely to
have
a college graduate around her and a lot
of males are dropouts the average woman
especially when a woman starts looking
for the possibility of having a child
and wanting a good father to be involved
she doesn't usually look in
among dropouts and she you know and 66
percent of the people between 25 and 31
who um lives live back at home
are male and she's not likely to go to
um to
back to go to bed with a guy who lives
in his
his parents basement um and she's not
likely to search unemployment lines and
the high school dropouts 20 somewhat
percent of high school dropouts are
unemployed for most of their twenties
and so this leaves a terrible market for
for girls and this is one of the reasons
i say we're all in the same family vote
and right right definitely when only one
sex wins both sexes lose and
unfortunately yes it's really sad that
we even have to say that because it's so
bloody obvious it's like whatever you do
to boys you do to girls yes
instantly and if you're not wise enough
to see that well then you should clue in
and if you do see it you proceed
nonetheless it's like yeah well we know
what you're up to
nothing but trouble
and and that is the huge
challenge with where feminism has been
going recently you know at least when i
was on the board of now in new york city
at least a portion of feminism was
saying um i am woman i am strong a la
helen ready and now it's mostly i am
woman i've been wronged and so we have
this hashtag me too
and i know a lot of women who have been
able to feel
able to speak up as a result of the
hashtag me too but having hashtag
me too as a monologue rather than having
hashtag me too as a dialogue is really a
crime because it makes women feel that
there are you know that they must be
right there's no response there's no
male experience uh that of of of him
being rejected by a woman or him uh have
been in a divorce situation and the
woman mouthing uh him to the the child
or there's no understanding that men who
are going through divorce are eight
times as likely as their their female
counterparts to commit suicide um you
know there's there's just no
understanding of that male experience
well there's also no there's i've talked
about this several times and become very
unpopular as a consequence but when i
studied anti-social behavior and
particularly at mcgill um
i studied female and male antisocial
behavior and
male antisocial behavior tends to be
much more physically violent and so most
of the people who are imprisoned are
male
mostly because we imprison violent
offenders
which is kind of interesting we don't
necessarily imprison
white-collar criminals even if they
defraud like 60 000 people but you know
a mugger well we're gonna lock them up
and yeah i can understand that although
not entirely because defrauding 60 000
people out of their pension isn't
exactly nothing either but in any case
it's almost all men in prison and it's
almost all violent offenders and so then
you say well what's the female
equivalent of anti-social personality
and that's a tough
question because it's much more subtle
but a lot of it is
reputation destruction and and exclusion
mean girl syndrome and everyone
understands that you can't play with us
for example that's a nice expression of
female antisocial behavior and that
reputation destruction also scales
really nicely on social media and so one
of the things i think is happening to
our whole culture is that we're
suffering from a radical influx of
female type antisocial behavior that's
cancel culture that's reputation
destruction and savaging
and so but we can't have a conversation
about that because all the pathology is
on the male side it's like no all the
pathology isn't on the male side plain
and simple there's
social pathologies that have a feminine
orientation that would be the
infantilization of everything and then
there's toxic femininity which is this
tendency to derogate and to savage
reputations and to escape scot-free in
the aftermath of that and the use of
manipulation and innuendo and
all of that very very difficult to cope
with uh very difficult to put boundaries
around too
so especially on social media
so
we and we tend to have very little
empathy for the way these behaviors have
uh evolved over over the years um you
know women had to sort of have uh talk
about men reputation-wise because um
before birth control and when maurice
were extremely uh strict if a male
wanted to be sexual with a woman and
maybe promised her uh that she would be
he would be marrying her and she said
okay i could you know maybe we'll be
married but then she talks to other
women and she finds out from eight or
ten other women well wait a minute he's
been said that to me he said that to me
he said that to mary over there and then
suddenly so that that will the thing
that we call gossip was very much a
protective mechanism on the part of
women to protect themselves from being
becoming pregnant with somebody that
really uh was not at all interested in a
long-term relationship and being a
long-term father conversely with with um
guys and women in terms of the no with
what no means know what no means maybe
whatnot means yes it was very helpful
for women to be able to say no before
birth control for obvious reasons but
even short of birth control
she discovers how does a man handle
rejection does he um if he if she says a
and no
and he stops right away and never tries
again
how will that translate into him being a
good salesperson
what successful man have you ever seen
or a woman have you ever seen stopped at
the no and didn't try again um and so
she but on the other hand the way he
tried the manner in which he tried the
respect he showed as he tried uh the the
way the way he manipulated his
persistence in a positive or negative
way
those were things that gave her a great
deal of information about what type of
father what type of um
breadwinner he would be
yeah well and if she puts obstacles in
his way and frustrates him and he gets
violent well then that's a pretty good
marker of his inability to deal with
let's say the frustration of a toddler
precisely and and that is um and those
are all so
i the the where i was going with that is
that there's that
we need to look at the behaviors we
castigate
and um and have
under an understanding of where they
came from and why and you were you're
talking about oftentimes chimpanzees and
different types of animals well and
among all animals from insects right out
of to humans um for the most part uh the
insects with a couple of exceptions of
the i'm sorry the uh the all the animals
seek males to reproduce with that are
alpha males
and um they they have no interest in um
the the the non-alpha males and you see
what the result of that is um among you
know buck um
antelope uh the the the moment those
males and females get together uh she uh
chooses the male that has the largest
rack and uh but that rack is such a
burden on him that he has to get rid of
it um immediately after the after
intercourse uh otherwise because the
rack in order to develop that rack uh
exhausts 30 of the minerals and
nutrition and calcium in his system and
if he doesn't immediately get rid of the
rack
he's going to end up having to probably
die if winter sets in before he gets rid
of that and does he doesn't have a
chance to replenish all his nutrients
and what that amounts to
is that here is the male
that looked the strongest the alpha male
um and it was served a purpose from the
females point of view of being able to
to um to keep away um other people that
wanted to have sex with her
that that were not as strong as he but
it was really a very good example of
men's weakness being their facade of
strength
and whether it's saying i'm strong
because i have my guns um or the the
fellow that was that that wrote me
also from texas you know saying i i i
got my guns together i was you know
going to do this mass shooting um i'm
going to be really
a strong man uh these are all these are
all vulnerabilities and these are masks
uh the the gun is the mask of
vulnerability it's the
expression of anger uh
also stunningly unsophisticated you know
one of the things you do with
aggressive young boys so
i don't remember if we talked about this
before but
um
there's a large branch of literature
focusing on
violent
two-year-olds
so about five percent of two-year-olds
males almost all males
kick hit bite and steal
and so if you put them with other
two-year-olds that's what they do
most of them are socialized out of that
by the age of four
the ones who aren't become unpopular
with their peers and then they get
outcast and then they're alienated and
then they're bullies and juvenile
delinquents and then they tend to be
criminals and
so it's basically career criminality
that begins at the age of two now the
question is what happens to the
two-year-olds
who are aggressive who are socialized
and the freudian answer would be that
that aggression is repressed but i don't
buy that i think really what happens is
that if those boys are
fortunate they have a sophisticated
father or father surrogate
who helps them develop
much more effective and sophisticated
strategies for their competitive
dominance
and that can be unbelievably useful then
you can have the man who is the beast in
beauty and beast who's very capable and
competent and
competitive
and willing to strive forward but also
sophisticated in his strategy choice and
so the two-year-old the aggressive
two-year-olds who are socialized out of
it
they become they get popular by the age
of four because they learn to play with
others and it's not because they're
repressing it's because they're
integrating
and yes that should be the model for us
is it's the integration and so that's
why i'm i'm really never happy when i
hear what we should all play
non-competitive games it's like first of
all it's not obvious that that's a game
by the way and second says who right how
about we regulate the expression of
ambition and aggression in the course of
competitive games like a good coach does
on the football field like what the
hell's wrong with that exactly why is
that not the right model and like
roughhousing does i mean
right the father that roughhouses and um
and does boundary enforcement uh
requires the child to um to think of his
brothers or sisters needs and which is
one of the reasons why roughhousing is
statistically related to
roughhousing combined with boundary
enforcement is statistically related to
empathy because you're requiring your
child to understand that somebody else
other than you
has to be considered here you can't
stick your um
your elbow in your brother or sister's
face uh in order to win at the
roughhousing you have to know the
difference between being assertive
versus aggressive and it's only under
the activation of that and things like
rough housing
where those lessons can be learned not
just in theory the mother's saying
always be kind to people or always not
um that doesn't translate until you
really put it into practice and you yeah
well the rough housing is a really good
example of that because
imagine what you're learning in when
you're
rough and tumble playing is first of all
you learn
how much can i be bent twisted and hurt
before the game isn't fun and that's not
theoretical it's like well you're going
to get bumped around a bit you're going
to get thrown into the air like there's
actual physical
threat occurring
but it can occur at a level that
actually heightens the thrill of the
game
and so of course most of the competitive
games especially the physical ones
run right on that edge so it's like it's
not no threat it's optimal threat and
that's a really tough thing and then and
then you so you've got to figure out how
dangerous can this be so that the fun is
optimized that's really tricky
and you negotiate that with your play
partner and then
well how far can i bend dad's arm or his
finger or his nose and and can i grab
his mustache can i grab his beard can
what can i do to the other person
that they're going to find provocative
and teasy and fun but not
painful and threatening same thing
you're doing when you're playing with a
dog and all of that's deeply embodied
right it's not it's not conceptual
it's it it actually constitutes the
prerequisite for the conceptualization
of something like empathy i think the
empathy emerges in part because
well we're gonna we're gonna rough and
tumble play or we're gonna play football
or or soccer for that matter we're going
to be rough with each other
as much as we possibly can
but we all want the game to continue yes
and that that's the crucial issue there
is to to play in a manner that enables
you to win but that also enables the
game to continue and you learn that in
competitive games and that's where
some very important lessons come in so
when a dad stops the game because the
rough housing has gone too far and
somebody's gotten hurt or it looks like
they will get hurt and then then the
children that are playing the rough
house doing the rough housing with the
dad have to say all right if
if my rough housing be is being stopped
that means what i really want
immediately my immediate gratification
which is to push my brother or sister
aside
is
i have to learn postpone gratification
because i really want the rough housing
but that roughhousing is is going to be
over with if i don't consider somebody
else's needs per my dad's um recognition
the extension of that into sexual
behavior with women is quite obvious
it's like there has to be a physical
there has to be physical contact
but it has to be undertaken in a subtle
enough manner so that it's going to
continue and so that's a way more
sophisticated
application of the same issue but it's
on the same continuum that's partly why
people dance and partly that is too the
women are checking out the men is like
well
can we be reasonably close together in
an in a manner highly suggestive of
intimacy
and you're still able to control
yourself in a socially acceptable manner
it's like is there a more direct test of
your
of your socialization history than that
probably not
absolutely and it is
and and that dance i mean you know the
tango is a perfect expression of male
female relationships and you know and
and when we it it has to be a two-sided
affair to happen but back on that um
roughhousing issue the the importance of
what that child is learning is that
postponed gratification and that
postponed gratification as we both know
is the biggest predictor of success and
fail or failure in life
and the kids that don't have that um
tend to um to fail in the postponed
gratification area that that leads them
to being depressed about their own
abilities and ashamed
like uh with salvador ramos the mass
shooter in texas not having graduated
from high school that led him to feeling
so just ashamed of himself he um when
his mother and he got into a fighter
grandmother and he got into a fight
about it she he shoots the grandmother
um so people that do you know do not
have that postponed gratification uh set
and they don't have a way of uh of of
being victorious in their playing in
that when they're two years old like you
were talking about i don't think it's a
matter of repression i think it's a
matter of when you are able to play and
get along with other kids and have the
game you have the capacity for
expression
and you don't have to worry about it
repression becomes a non-issue it was
yeah that's right
yeah i think that's absolutely right i
mean you know piaget pointed out quite
clearly when he analyzed the structure
of iterable games and so
and there's a morality that comes out of
that is that you have to regulate your
behavior in accordance with the
willingness of others to voluntarily
play with you
and so that that spirit of voluntary
play in some sense is a marker for a
sustainable reciprocal ethos
and so and you also mean one of the
things that i did with my kids when they
were little because we used to exchange
jokes all the time and
and and
the rule was you get to be funny but you
don't but you can stay you stay on the
fun end of funny because funny can
easily degenerate into teasing and it
can become mean and what's really
interesting about that is that
the fun part of that is right on the
edge right it's right where i'm saying
something to you that's so provocative
that it's almost too much but not quite
that's where it's really funny and you
can see that as a really subtle testing
of the boundary so my son was quite
assertive when he as a young child
he he was he was a kid he had his own
will man he's really still like that as
an adult and it was very interesting to
interact with him because
he would
come home safe from daycare and he'd
absorbed a bunch of evil spirits at
daycare and he'd come home and
manifest all sorts of behavioral
patterns that we were just not putting
up with and
now and then he'd he'd
push it too far for a couple of days and
i'd get together with my wife and we
would we would negotiate like okay that
kid's getting out of control we're not
gonna let him
do anything out of the out of the proper
bounds of propriety whatsoever for like
a week watch him like a hawk and we'd
agree on that and every single time we
did that
he liked both of us better yes and it
was so interesting to watch and partly i
realized to some degree in retrospect is
that
that focused attention man there from
adults there is nothing more valuable
than that to a kid and they'll misbehave
to evoke that boundary setting because
it's so utterly crucial for their
development
i wonder why kids will misbehave and to
attract attention it's like there's
nothing they just like the school
shooters there's nothing they want more
than attention
it really it's it is amazing to me the
degree to which the need for attention
is is so dominant among all of us and
yeah um and many of us have learned to
channel it and you and i have learned to
channel it in ways that you know that
that um that that help others and where
we think help others and i think
some people would disagree yeah yeah
we we delusionally believe that we help
others right right right right
um
the
let's go to the teasing thing for a
moment i i think one of the differences
between the dad style parenting and mom
style parenting is that when that dads
will often tease and moms will often fee
and then the child will sometimes when
if that child that has not been teased
much or at all before that is
predominantly brought up usually by a
mom who is much less likely to tease
when the dad teases the child will often
cry and the mom will get
feel that the dad is being very
insensitive because he made the child
cry
um and you therefore don't know much
about parenting and how to not make the
child cry but if and dads aren't very
good at explaining that well when i
tease it's it's a way of like
teasing is like at its best it's like
having a vitamin in a fruit smoothie um
the cream the vitamin is the criticism
and the fruit smoothie makes the
criticism not more palatable um by not
tasting it so directly it's that the
wheatgrass does not you know sting your
mouth um and so the uh and so dads will
often say you know well you something
like oh well you got away with that one
didn't you are you
are you sort of um um but you you um you
lied to that little boy and um and he
believed what you said
um you know um uh that's that's great
you're going to be a champion liar
someday do you want you you think lying
should be in the olympics um you know
that type of thing and the boy will be
able or the girl will be able to pick up
the fact that dad has noticed that she
or he lies notices that lying is not
really being approved of um but at the
at the same time is not being yelled at
being told you know you just lied you
shouldn't lie right right well it's also
a good way of developing resilience it's
like because you're going to be tested
with frustration and disappointment
constantly in the social and natural
world and so to prod a bit is to also
build up resilience the same way the
immune system adapts to a certain level
of pathogen in the environment you don't
want a pathogen-free environment you
want
a pathogen representative environment
and so by
by
what would you say challenging your
children on a variety of fronts
emotional and physical
you
first of all they get used to the fact
that that can happen because it is
definitely going to happen to them and
one of the things that's very
interesting about bullies is uh dan
always wrote a great book on bullying uh
i don't know if it's in print anymore
bullying what we know and what we can do
about it very straightforward title he
cut bullying rates in scandinavia by 50
by the way and he showed that you know
there's there's typical bullies but
there's also typical bully victims
and the bully victims are typically
selected by the bullies because of what
the bullies will do is throw out some
teasing you know one person after
another and the the victim who responds
with too much infantile behavior
to the teasing which might mean bursting
into tears for example or running to a
teacher then it's like well now you're
the target
and so
and so without that preparation
of teasing and comedy and all of that
then you send your children unarmed out
into the world to face
well
people who are going to be far worse
for them than
you know the the little devil that's the
glint in the father's eye when he says
something witty but with a barb in it
yes so this one you were talking about
this gentleman being from scandinavia
and uh when i when i was in denmark
doing some speaking there was a um
i i went to some danish schools and they
they do communication skills training in
first second third grade where the bully
and the bullied will come off from you
know not just the bully and the bullied
um but you know the kids in the
playground will you know once a week or
so uh talk about what happened on that
playground
and and the bullied person gets to share
what happened from his or her
perspective the bully gets to share what
happens from his or her
from their perspective right right so
they get to negotiate well not only yes
negotiate and also
just see
that what they've just done has hurt
somebody else right right right right
yeah when my kids were little and one of
them would tease the other into tears
let's say or i always made the
bully let's say
look at the other child because one of
the things i noticed was that if they
were
on a little bullying binge
and they made the other person cry then
they would avoid noticing yeah they said
no no you look you look you look and you
see what happened and generally that
would evoke that empathic response
one of the things that might be
interesting for people to hear is that
well if you're a single mother you have
a dearth of of positive role male role
models in your life for your son for
your daughter what do you think might be
done about that that would be productive
yeah um a number of things first is to
unders
understand
what dads do that is different from what
moms do
um and because when dads are appreciated
for what they do
appreciated for their teasing up to a
point
appreciated for their rough housing up
to a point appreciated for their
encouragement of kids to take risks up
to a point and you're counter balancing
well first you're letting the your dad
know that that rough housing leads to
empathy that the uh that the uh focus on
um a good boundary leads to postponed
gratification that leads to success that
leaves them feeling better about
themselves so when you let a biological
dad know that you need that from him
men are biologically programmed to
respond to being needed
when every generation had its war and we
told men we need you to be willing to
die men were willing to die in the
millions in order to serve to do
something to keep other people alive so
just don't underestimate if you're a mom
listening to this don't underestimate
how much dads
how much we need to learn about what
dads do and the value of what they
contribute
so i gotta i want to add something to
that that's practical too so this is
good for
for for couples to know in general
so when you're you've got to have some
sense first of all imagine your mother
and you you think well i'd like my son
and my daughter to have a good
relationship with their fathers now you
got to think about well you want a good
relationship you want them to love each
other you want them to play together you
want them to communicate
okay so you kind of got that as a
distant vision but now you're watching
your husband and your kids
and now and then you're going to see
something happening that really makes
you pretty happy
that's a really good time to say hey you
know what i just saw that and it made me
really happy we could have some more of
that yes and that like even skinner b.f
skinner the animal behaviorist he
learned
that the best way to train animals was
to use reward not punishment or threat
and it's a hell of a skill to develop to
watch your family members interact and
then to see when they're doing something
that makes you think oh my god if we had
that happening 10 times a day wouldn't
this be a much better household and then
to say that you can get a tremendous way
with that so
single mothers women listening to this
if you see your husband and your kids
interacting together
and and it's going well and they're
smiling they're laughing they're playing
and it's going nicely you want to
you want to reward that and you
definitely don't want to punish it
unless you want it to disappear and you
know some distrust might emerge is is it
okay if my husband's doing that it's
like if the kids are enjoying it
you know that's not a bad marker
absolutely and the
as you know um joe and i teach couples
communication courses and one of the
things that is really important is not
is both appreciating and also training
that developing the discipline to take
the that appreciation to a deeper level
so a man might say you know i love
you're a great cook um and but when he
says you know i really love
i really love the way you cook that
turkey that begins to feel a little bit
more um like i was really seen but right
right that's specificity right
man that gravy you made you know i
noticed that you put just exactly the
right amount of flour and it wasn't it
was brown perfectly and he brought it to
the table heated and
like it was spiced so well that
specificity of reward is that's an
unbelievably powerful technique because
it shows that you attend it eh exactly
and you're saying is you know is that
parsley sage rosemary
the specificity of appreciation combined
with curiosity like you know right right
how did you do it so well tell me more
about it yeah show me what you did yeah
is there a way we could do more of that
man that's a great thing that's a great
thing to sprinkle through your entire
relationship yes and and sprinkle
through let's work with that that that
what you just said there is so important
most couples they hear that in a
couple's communication workshop and they
say oh that's really important very nice
but then they never go out and do it
part of what i do with my couples is
that is to work on the the subtitle of
the course is the art and discipline of
love and almost right almost nobody
associates discipline with love but you
know doing this appreciation and three
of them like my wife and i do every
wednesday night in our case um or um
with with a routine
doesn't leave the appreciations coming
to your partner when they at awake which
is often right what happens um and so
this this um this training to appreciate
um and then doing it frequently and
doing it systematically um this is so
much an important part of a couple of
yeah well it really works well with kids
too in terms of encouraging them so if
you see your kid doing something you
know like maybe they bring you a picture
to show you
and you and you know you glance at you
say well that's nice and that's the end
of it it's like
yeah
they came to show you that so maybe you
take the picture and you say
was that a sun it's like you see you
drew the rays there the rays look really
good and while those flowers look good
and what were you trying to do with this
and maybe you could put a chimney on you
did a real good job here and this part's
particularly good and here's why like to
do a differentiated analysis of that
well people love that especially if you
can
when my students used to write me essays
a lot of them especially the initial
essays were just bloody awful like
almost everything about them was awful
but now and then they'd throw in a
sentence you know that was real it would
just sort of stand out like a diamond
i'd circle it and say
yeah
more of this and then the next dsa would
be like 30
that and then 60 percent that you know
yes it really is
we are you know we have a part of our
brain it's called the rcz rostral
singlet zone and when and when we get
approval uh that sends dopamine to that
part of our brain it is just amazing how
much we are all um you know we are all
in need of that of that dopamine and it
makes us feel so much more loved
let me go back for a second if i may to
the
what are the things a mom can do so
let's say that there's that the mom does
not have a biological father that it is
possible to bring in their in their life
a lot of moms look out for stepfathers
but oftentimes particularly if they have
daughters
they are very the
the father behavior
combined with being a stepfather often
makes the biological mom feel that the
father does the biological the
stepfather does not have as much
investment in protecting the child and
so when the moms see that the child is
crying as a result of the roughhousing
crying as a result of the teasing or
maybe
fell from too high a spot that the the
father let them go to
instead of seeing this as a contribution
to the children that the stepfather is
bringing
fears that the stepfather doesn't love
and have as much investment in the
children and therefore the stepfather
becomes a vice president in the family
as opposed to an equal um
having a very equal relationship and
that can happen very subtly you know and
it's so interesting to watch couples do
that like i've seen lots of
mothers in particular
just viciously punish their husbands for
interacting with their children so the
husband will take some steps he'll he'll
start to play and maybe he does it
somewhat roughly and she'll just be in
there protecting the child from the
father like right now and you do that
like a hundred times and the game's over
you've permanently disrupted the
relationship between the father and the
child because you're also broadcasting
massive signals of distrust to the child
it's like well your father's so
dangerous that we can't even let him
play with you a little bit it's like not
good
and it doesn't allow the father to
develop any skills either that way and
he ends up debating developing what i
call the father's catch-22 he learns a
lot to love the family by being away
from the love of the family and earning
more money okay you know i will take
that job you know selling product x um
nationwide uh i'm really not needed
around here so much um but the one thing
my wife does appreciate is my bringing
in more income so we can buy a better
home and a better neighborhood a better
school district okay i'm rewarded for
that i'm definitely not being rewarded
for the playing that i'm doing and so a
lot of dads that you know in wanting
that reward
they see the one way that they're um
they're they're um lovable and they
don't realize that you know the data
shows that once a a once a family has
depending on where in the united states
they live they're earning between fifty
thousand and seventy five thousand a
year
um that that that that what the children
need is more of that
time not more attention yeah you better
or not more of dad's time and so that
and so that's important to remember but
if let's say there's no stepfather and
no biological dad um it's very important
for
parents and mother the mother
to get the child involved with cub
scouts two years in cub scouts has shown
um
very good studies
with control groups that kids that do
and don't go to cub scouts um leading to
children developing better character and
i don't know a single mother doesn't
want the child to have better character
to get them involved not just in sports
but in
in what i call the liberal arts of
sports by the liberal arts and sports i
mean uh organized sports really helps
them to pay attention to somebody who is
creating structure for them and know
what structure to do but it's also if
they want to be an entrepreneur or an
original thinker it's pick up team
sports is really helpful for that
because you're saying okay are we are
you negotiating everything
right we're going to play full court
we're going to play half court in
basketball uh who do i choose um last
time that jordan and i played together i
passed the ball to him and he got a and
he and he and he got the and he got the
point okay i can pass that ball to him
again i can trust when he reaches out
for it but i i threw that ball of the
bill and every time he missed okay um
and you know and what what's a foul um
and you know is is a foul being pushed a
little bit or a lot um you know uh how
how ex how am i exhausting myself
quickly by running back and forth
in the court and so all these things
become so many things that are
unsupervised behavior and the ability of
people to sort of like gauge
all the subtleties of like we were
talking about with what no means no what
no means maybe all these subtleties are
much more easily able to be picked up
from pickup team sports and because of
so many of our fears as parents we've
often been discouraging our children
from doing pick-up team sports we
haven't been willing to leave them leave
them at the school and maybe maybe they
do get into a fight at school um but
it's
important to allow them to get into that
fight and then
process what were the red flags that
that told you that this was a this was a
situation that might lead to a fight and
protecting this also an opportunity to
practice reconciliation i mean one of
the things dewall has shown and
this is very interesting in relationship
to this alpha idea and this is a good
thing for the young men who are
listening to really take note of this
dewall has shown quite clearly that
sometimes it's the smallest male chimp
in the troop who's the alpha
and that's often a male who's very good
at negotiating reciprocal relationships
very good at uh reconciliation
post-conflict and often allied with a
powerful female who's
kin related to many of the other chimps
in the group and has powerful social
standing dewall has shown very clearly
that
if a chimp uses
pure physical power as a means of
attaining alpha status that the troop is
fractious that his rule is short and
that his end is brutal and that the
alphas that are successful are the most
reciprocal
individuals often in the entire troop
yes it's all friendship coalition
reconciliation
alliance building and that's and chimps
have a patriarchal structure
fundamentally a patriarchal social
structure so they're a good analog of
the evil patriarchy in some real sense
but
even in that even among the animal and
animals the chimpanzees
the mere expression of power is a is a
it's a unstable social strategy it's by
no means optimal and i think that's very
tightly associated with our discussion
earlier about delay of gratification and
the spirit of play so you have to
integrate that aggression into an
iterable and desirable social game a
mating game and a friendship game and a
cooperation game and a competition game
all of that that's not repression and
that's not
that's not the eradication of toxic
masculinity it's the socialization of
ambition absolutely crucially important
we're going to talk a little bit about
what might be done on the legislative
front as well yeah i
um on a personal level i got a letter
from chris sproules about um six months
ago um saying that he had three uh chris
brows was the speaker of the house of
florida um saying that he um had three
sons and he did a lot of these things
that we were talking about like the
rough housing and that helped him
explain this to his wife
and and then he gave it to two of the
the republican democratic leaders in the
relevant areas of legislation in the
house of representatives of florida
and they drew up legislation based on a
need to bring more fathers into
developing something that they call the
fatherhood crisis
and what was most um rewarding to me
was that the legislation passed the
house with a one hundred percent uh a
unanimous
vote on the part of both the democrats
and republicans hooray um and usually
democrats are much more resistant to
understanding the value of dads in the
family and so i was really proud of them
yeah yeah a new kid that's great for
doing that yeah so what do you think
that'll translate into practically
well so far they've um
allocated 75 million dollars to develop
programs some of it is traditional stuff
around child support
but others is um
stuff that isn't just child support by
money
but child support by dad involvement
which is the more important type of
right right support and to the degree
that they um execu and there's a number
of fathers groups in florida uh that are
really very um i imagine will be very
much involved in the um and the helpful
execution of that um and so
what i would like to see in florida is
the development of fatherhood programs
that tell men
a you're needed b here's what you do
differently so
see here's how you communicate with your
wife respectfully so that when she says
it's not okay to climb the tree you're
too young to the child and the dad
says oh don't be overprotective how to
negotiate some way of like climbing that
tree so the child can climb up to a
certain point but not beyond a certain
point so dad can be under the tree uh to
be able to cushion a fall and not have a
cell phone with them and so the mom and
dad can do what i call checks and
balance parenting
the data shows that the children that do
best have both a mom and dad that are
actively involved and obviously the
children that that do the best have a
parents that end up staying together yet
getting divorced well they do opponent
processing you know because yes
so if you want to move your hand
smoothly this way
the best way to do it is to put your
other hand there and push against it
then you can make yeah yeah so that's an
opponent process and a lot of very
fine-grained attunements
and calibrations are opponent processes
and so you imagine
how lenient versus
permissive should you be with a child
and the answer is
well it depends on the child in this
situation and so how do you negotiate
that and the answer is well imagine you
have on the maternal side this more
all-encompassing love that's forgiving
but can move towards overprotectiveness
and on the paternal side you have this
forward encouragement that can be too
pushy
and that has to be calibrated to the
child how do you calibrate it and the
answer is well the parents negotiate and
the woman pushes and the man pushes and
they find a balance that optimizes that
situation for the child and then
everybody gets what they need if if
things if we're lucky
and the challenge there is each person
negotiating
often feels the person hearing that
negotiation of well we could do it
differently in this way
the person making the suggestion of the
negotiation is often perceives himself
or herself as making a suggestion for a
better
connection with the children etc the
person hearing any suggestion of of a
change and behavior or attitude that is
expected or required of that person
perceives him or herself as being
criticized right right right yeah that's
a tough one to negotiate and the single
biggest uh flaw in the the single
biggest achilles heel of human beings is
our inability to handle personal
criticism without becoming defensive
and well you know you can open up a
discussion i i did this a lot with my
clinical clients because there were
often things they didn't want to discuss
and i said well look here here's the
here's the deal here
we're going to open up the discussion
and lay out a whole variety of options
we are not going to start with the
assumption that any of these options are
correct or that they're mandatory
or that they're criticisms of you
and we're not going to proceed until we
agree and that actually works quite
nicely in familial interactions like
well let's have a talk we're not going
to assume that you're right and i'm
right or or and we're not going to try
to establish who's right we're going to
open up the discussion space we're going
to evaluate all the different
possibilities
and then before we move forward we're
going to agree
and i mean
it's so interesting to me too that you
know we we're so bad at teaching people
to negotiate they have no idea how to do
it and so they do hear any suggestion of
something different as a criticism it's
that's just a non-starter right because
if you're trying to negotiate with your
partner and every time you make a
suggestion
you're treated as if you're disrupting
their self-esteem in some fundamental
way it's like it's too much effort yes i
also counseled people to make the
discussion about the smallest thing
possible it's part of that specificity
it's like
well
exactly what time do we want our child
to go to bed
precisely and why
well you know is it 7 30 is it 7 45 is
it 8 o'clock how much time do we need to
spend for ourselves so that we don't get
irritated at the child what's
appropriate developmentally let's get it
precise and then we can negotiate well
exactly what is the routine going to be
when we put the child to bed and what
deviations are we going to tolerate and
how do we deal with the deviations
jointly
and that it's so nice for a child to
have
a parental unit that
is
unified in relationship to boundary
enforcement
because the children will play one child
one parent against the other if they can
because they're conniving little devils
and very very smart and and they're
motivated to do that but it's such a
relief to them to see that the walls
hold
they'll test them and you think well
it's mean to put up the walls it's like
no it's not
paradise is a walled garden
and the children need the walls because
otherwise they face an infinite expanse
of complexity and so they'll test not
because they don't want the walls but
because they bloody well want to know
where they are yeah yeah the children
without the boundary enforcement or the
without those walls they most children
are like they feel like they're walking
in the dark on a platform that they
don't know where they're going to fall
off um right right right that's a good
metaphor but when they see the walls
they know that but it engenders much
more security the process i use in the
couples workshop that i do is um
is because i feel it's biologically
unnatural to hear personal criticism
from a loved one without becoming
defensive um i i
have people alter their natural
biological space first so that they um
they they alter their consciousness into
six mindsets that they say for example
like if i um one i call the love
guarantee in which they say that i if i
provide a safe environment for all of
your feelings your fears your anger
without becoming defensive and and just
to hold that space for you you'll feel
safer with me and therefore more love
from me and therefore for more love for
me
um and that's just yeah that that i
asked people um to to say
whether or not they would be willing to
um take a 50 risk of dying if their
partner was about ready to be killed um
but they um but they knew with um that
that with 100 certainty that they could
save their life and about 95 of men say
that they will risk they would risk
their life uh for their partner and
understand that some of these partners
that come to the couple's workshop many
of them are very secure in their
relationship but others are thinking
about getting a divorce or just breaking
up or not you know that type of thing so
even among their 95 percent of the men
are willing to take a 50 risk of dying
in order to save their partner's uh life
if they know 100 certainly
certainty they can do that and
surprisingly 85 or so of the women feel
this say the same thing about the men
and they're all making these statements
on pieces of yellow paper that their
partner that they wrinkle throw throw
into the
center of the room um and
their partner never discovers what they
have what what their answer is but the
first mindset then becomes if i'm
willing to die to give you life
then i'm then i can listen to give you
life right right right right so and then
when they've meditated themselves into
that and other mindsets like that for
about a half hour but not much more than
a half hour they're able to hear
anything their partner says in whatever
way they say it
including exaggerations and lies
and yeah well you have to be willing to
let your partner go off the mark a bit
because otherwise you can't have a
discussion the other thing i i
recommended to people which i think is
very useful
tell me what you think about this is
i always suggested that they specify
their conditions for satisfaction it's
like so let's say i have a beef with you
it's like
okay well here's some things about
what you did i don't like well that's
pretty generic and i don't know how to
bind that it's like well is this a
criticism of me right to the core or
what's going on it's like
what do you want me to do
like if i could redo that
and you would be satisfied with what i
did what exactly would i have to do or
say and i think you can even do that
you know maybe you respond badly to your
wife's new outfit and she's disappointed
that can be very subtle
and maybe you're you do that because
you're you know you're just not that
bright and so she's not happy because
you didn't respond well you can say
what would you like to have heard me say
and you know the first response to that
is well if i have to tell you then it
doesn't mean anything or you don't
really care but the response to that is
well assume i'm stupid and i need to do
this 50 times before i'll be even
vaguely sophisticated at it and give me
a break i'll i'll deliver what you want
badly in the hopes of being able to do
it better in the future and that i think
is a very effective technique but it
it's combined with that willingness to
let your partner do for you what you
need
badly to begin with because then you get
to learn at least you know
i think that's that's an important way
and i also find that
when
um someone is just complaining
and they know it's safe to complain
and they can say it in whatever tone of
voice they want or exaggerated whatever
whatever and then even if they
incorporate in that complaint a request
for it to be done differently
when they're finished the process if
they're really heard well and seen
let them know what you've heard them say
and so on i have learned
not to
respond by telling my wife
i will agree to do what she mentions in
the process because oftentimes when she
feels adequately heard
what she was asking for in that process
is no longer yeah well well that's
that's part of the calibration right
it's like the person is going to have to
[__] and whine a lot to kind of cover
the territory and one of the things you
discover this is certainly something you
discover in clinical work is that
people have to listen to what they think
and then they can discard like 80
percent of it's like oh well actually
you know some of that i just i didn't
really mean or doesn't seem relevant
anymore but you don't bloody well know
that when it's bubbling up inside you
yes and so that's another reason to
that's a difficult thing to learn to
forestall that
sense of guilt and and criticism that
comes in listening to the other person
express some negative emotion yeah but
knowing that knowing that a fair bit of
that will dissipate in the telling is
definitely a useful thing to a meta a
meta strategy to learn yeah so we should
stop here pretty quick we'd be going for
almost two hours so i i thought maybe
one thing we should do maybe both of us
separately
if there's anybody out there any young
guy for example
who's watching this
who's been having vengeful fantasies and
who has been developing and toying with
fantasies of revenge and who is feeling
isolated and lonesome and oppressed and
isolated and is starting to spin up
fantasies of violence in revenge
you know and you'll know that if you're
one of these people
like
find someone to talk to
there's better ways you can deal with
this and you're young you're 16 you're
17. you don't have to be doomed you know
you got your whole life ahead of you
and maybe just getting out of the place
that you're in where you're unpopular
might do it for you you know you can
move to somewhere else and be a new
person there's all sorts of pathways in
life
and so you don't have to explosively
demonstrate your competence you know in
a single vengeful violent act there are
better ways to deal with the world and
you might have reason to be bitter and
vengeful but
but there are better paths there are
better paths forward so don't do it do
what this
young man we talked about earlier did is
have enough sense to reach out to
somebody find someone a teacher a
principal someone
a policeman if it has to be
someone
yes and and i really encourage every
school system
to
um to
in the boy crisis book i have a suicide
depression inventory and there is every
home every mass shooting is a suicide
and so
i'd love to see that passed out to
everyone in school so that no one feels
singled out for being told that you
should take this inventory uh so you so
the kids see that so for example with
boys when boys
say that
three or four of the the principles that
that that tend to be very true for
almost all boys thinking these things is
feeling that no one loves them
[Music]
that no one needs them
there's no hope of that changing right
and if they do tell someone
that respects them that that person will
lose respect for them
those are just four examples of that and
if there's if these red flags of
depression or suicide are happening
then we need to reach out to these girls
and boys uh girls for different reasons
they're not going to shoot up the school
um but they may shoot up their own lives
in a in an internal type of way and we
don't want that for any of our our girls
or our boys
yeah well it's not nothing to go and
admit to someone that you know that
you've been having this sort of idea and
that you're in that much trouble that
takes a that takes a fair bit of
reorientation and moral courage but
the alternative is so cataclysmic and so
unnecessary absolutely and and so
appalling
that's so important that if you're a
legislator listening to this like what
kentucky is doing which is getting both
making sure that after a divorce that
both mothers and fathers have
are involved that equal shared parenting
is one of the four things that is
absolutely crucial for children having
the best opportunity right i want to
chime in on that too that that i would
definitely second that motion is that we
you know i thought for a long time maybe
that that giving women of very young
children primary custody might be the
best default solution but i don't
believe that anymore i think 50 50
custody should be the default
and
we have to start with this whole
understanding of the importance of
father right from the beginning we have
we have in the culture at this moment
right to life versus a woman's body a
woman's choice the discussion should be
an understanding that that almost all
rights are rights intention
by
we
the fetus has a right to live the mother
does have a right to choose but also the
complete the right that's been
completely left out
is the dad's right to have a choice the
dad's right to be notified immediately
whenever there's a pregnancy about the
fact that the mother is considering
abortion and being able to sign a piece
of
a legal document that's
an affidavit saying i will take
responsibility for this child for 18
years to raise the child financially and
emotionally and then
instead of having it be a debate between
aborting the child and a
mother's right of mother's choice we
have a whole third option there uh that
that may allow that fetus to become a
real live infant that's taken care of
for 18 years the mother and father both
had
did sex together
they both have responsibilities um if
for a woman to take nine nine months of
responsibility during pregnancy and a
man to take eight to in exchange for an
eighteen a year taking eighteen a man
taking 18 years of responsibility is um
in in in order to be able to allow that
child to live and be loved uh that's a
fair trade-off but that's not even in
the discussion now so when we when we
started well we're gonna we're a long
way in our society from being able to
have a mature discussion about sexuality
that's for sure and about the
consequences maybe that's something we
can try to do it on a future discussion
absolutely so
yeah all right so is there anything else
that we should close off with i mean
that was a pretty comprehensive
discussion and hopefully people will
find it useful
you know just um the importance of
family dinner night and knowing how to
connect that because the children that i
listened to that are also required to
listen to their brothers their sisters
and their parents are the children um in
conjunction with um checks and balance
parenting uh that those those are the
children that do the best
and where if if people want to read what
you've written that that say
specifically focuses on familial
communication patterns what what's the
best book for them do you think the boy
crisis is definitely the best and the
portions of the book and i have to say
that a lot of men in particular are
saying to me that they really like to
hear it on audible um because i i i read
my part and i hope my voice allows some
of the what i'm saying to have another
dimension to it right right right right
and john gray did a terrific job on uh
the guy who wrote men from mars wounded
from venus he did a terrific job on on
preventing and reversing adhd without
using drugs
okay okay well thank you very much for
talking to me again it's always
appreciated it's always a pleasure it's
really um i enjoy it and when i go back
over the um uh the the show i say oh yes
he said that that was so interesting and
so good i always really um i learned a
lot from the process as well and
hopefully we'll get where
one of the consequences of these sorts
of discussions is that we're going to
decrease the probability of the sorts of
terrible things that we're talking about
because that would be in everyone's
interests clearly so thank you thank you
again absolutely thank you